that was
the one new sequence that they shot that
zach shot for this movie
um as far as i know everything else
in the zack snyder version was footage
that was shot in 2017
but this was the one sequence they
wanted to add and it would have been it
was quite difficult for them as when it
was shot
the u.s was fairly strictly locked down
a lot of coveted problems and and even
getting a film crew on a set together
safely was quite difficult but they
managed to do it they managed to
hurt all the cats and and get that
shot and we only had i think a couple
shots
i think was the flash um he couldn't be
on set so
whatever actors couldn't actually be on
set to to shoot the new sequence we
added digitally
um or were shot in a remote location on
green
for their shots so that they could since
the whole sequence is in this
fantastical world
the entire sequence was shot on green
with some practical cars
and we're adding the the background so
it almost didn't matter
if you were alone in a shot where you
were you could have been in the north
pole you know wherever
the actors were if you could get a
camera on them over green then we could
put them into that world and make sure
everything matches and string it all
together
bvs was so long ago though tech wise for
us it was easier
to take the feeling of that sequence and
and look and
and do it from scratch while making sure
we honor
what it's supposed to look like